et nous avons trouvé et alexis poulain
notre éditorialiste pour évoquer la
décision rendue cet après midi par le
conseil constitutionnel qui valide à
l'essentiel du projet de loi concernant
la lutte contre le séparatisme texte
controversé adopté définitivement par le
parlement le 23 juillet on en parle tout
de suite avec alexis poulain
allait ciblant celles de mesures ont
donc été censurée concernant les
dissolutions d'associations et les
retraits de titre de séjour accordés aux
étrangers est ce que c'est là le coeur
de ce texte législatif
alors non ce n'est pas l'ailé coeur du
texte législatif puisque la plupart des
nouilles orage par sur l'éducation
privée je suis les contrôles de la
laïcité les deux professeurs etc mais
c'est quelque chose qui montre que
encore une fois c'est tout a été bâclée
elle a répondu à une urgence de
communication à une urgence aussi
médiatique plus qu à une réflexion
profonde sur des arts titution sur ce
qui fait la règle et 30 aides parce que
en réalité que disent les sages sur 7,4
séparatisme c'est que les mesures
notamment sur les associations le
respect des valeurs de la république
pour les individus également avec le
renouvellement du titre de séjour sont
trop flous pour permettre de juger par
le droit qui aurait ou n'aurait pas
respecté ses valeurs de la république et
qu'elle finalement quels sont donc même
si gérald darmanin se félicite on voit
bien que cette loi est record une loi de
deux postures une loi de marketing
politique il avait d'ailleurs à l'époque
satisfait ni la droite ni la gauche au
parlement puisque la droite pour ça que
cette attitude est trop timide et la
gauche une loi était déjà trop
liberticide et puis c'est une loi qui
rate son objet puisque déjà elle
s'appelle séparatisme que gérald
darmanin bien sûr a bien du mal utilisé
le terme de radicalisme islamique et que
au final je ne vois pas comment encore
une fois cette loi va s'appliquer dans
les faits avec ce nouveau ce nouvel
outil sur la laïcité mise en place par
marina pas pour en casser l'observatoire
de la laïcité qui a été déçu quelles
dispositions du texte que vous pointez
du doigt encore aujourd'hui
le texte en général même si l'intention
est la bonne c'est à dire défendre
principe de laïcité défendre les valeurs
de la république et s'assurer de la non
prolifération de discours de haine c'est
l'application qui me paraît difficile
délicate et c'est pour ça que je parle
de loi de posture de loi de marketing
politique parce que aujourd'hui sur le
financement notamment des lieux de culte
par l'étranger sur la façon dont sont
formés les différents responsables
religieux hillman et autres il n'y a
rien vraiment qui a été fait pour
avancer dans cette direction là et sur
le contrôle des associations on a vu
très facilement à des associations qui
ont été dissoutes par gérald darmanin à
l'époque de discussions sur ce texte qui
ont tout simplement ouvert un bureau en
belgique ainsi la forte baisse des aides
association de droit belge et qui font
exactement la même chose du côté de
l'autre côté de la frontière et qui
opèrent sur le territoire français comme
elle le faisait auparavant donc c'est un
texte extrêmement rentable qui ne permet
pas d'émettre en platine allemand des
lois de descente et il est les
professeurs seule face aux conséquences
et à la difficulté d'apprendre la
laïcité d'apprendre le respect de la
parole le fait qu'en france il n'y a pas
de déni blast âme on se rappelle tous
bien sûr de la mort tragique et violente
de sympathie ses professeurs qui avaient
osé parler de choses donc il devrait
parler tout simplement ses principes de
laïcité je crois que dans les écoles
jean michel blanquer on n'a pas mis en
place non plus de protocole pour
accompagner les professeurs dans cette
tâche me paraît délicate maintenant
alors on l'a entendu à le ministre de
l'intérieur dharmanand se réjouir sur
twitter de cette décision le conseil
constitutionnel qu'il se retrouve
renforcé d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui
aux ressources et non mais disons que
c'est une loi qui est passé heureusement
gérald darmanin a du pain sur la planche
déjà je crois avec les nombreux préfets
les manifestations contre le pass
sanitaires qui ont lieu partout en
france alors les sites de préfectures un
permettre de minimiser la mobilisation
mais elle est énorme et pour demain je
pense qu'elle va être encore plus
nombreuses donc
je crois qu'il veut être jugé sur cette
gestion la halle d'abord en espérant
qu'il n'y ait pas de violence et puis
même si la poussée en cette joie sur le
séparatisme elle est pour moi doit de
marketing politique et nous importante
pour gérald darmanin puisqu'il a défait
un peu son profil politique 1 sur cette
lutte contre l'islamisme radical mais on
voit bien que in fine et il n'y aura pas
de renforcement des mesures le cas
encore récemment tragique du meurtre
d'un trade par en rendait sur le sol
français montre bien que il ya
l'administration est dépassé et
finalement
on respecte le droit tel qu'il est et
même si ces lois de posture politique ça
qu'une il s'est multiplié le
millefeuille français rien ne change
defacto dans la gestion des risques du
contrôle judiciaire des nombreux
jihadistes qui vont sortir de prison par
exemple dans les mois qui viennent merci
beaucoup pour votre regard alexis
paulhan